Speaker 1: Hey, this is really funny.
This is not the biggest news story.
But Ted Cruz went to Yankee Stadium, a place
I have spent many, many hours at.
And he was at Yankee Stadium because the Houston
Astros Texas baseball team are playing against
the New York Yankees and everything about
it is just completely humiliating.
At one point, Ted Cruz cheering for the wrong
team.
But the funniest part is actually something
that has dramatically improved my opinion
of Yankees fans.
I've been to many.
You know, I grew up in Massachusetts.
I'm a Red Sox fan, but I've gone to many,
many games at Yankee Stadium when the Red
Sox come to town.
And I, you know, never cause any trouble or
anything like that.
But trouble sometimes finds its way to Yankee
Stadium during big rivalries.
And I have to tell you that I just love, love,
love the Yankee fans here.
Here they are noticing that Ted Cruz is coming
in.
Listen to the treatment he gets.
Unidentified: You know, my sisters are no
longer you.
Speaker 3: You're right.
You know, here you're.
Unidentified: One drunk, older white boy.
Speaker 3: This insurrection.
Yeah.
Go, go, go, go.
Get out of your way.
Unidentified: What are you doing here?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So really getting the full treatment there
from the Yankee fans.
Also, another really funny moment in this
in this clip you're going to see.
The Yankees pitcher strikes out the Houston
batter.
And you see Ted Cruz wearing a bright orange
shirt and a vest right behind home plate.
He cheers at the guy he's supposed to be rooting
for striking out.
Cruz doesn't know what's going on.
I'm going to play this actually without audio.
You can see here in comes the pitch and then
it's in there for a called third strike.
And Ted Cruz, cheers.
Speaker 3: Luke's.
Oh, dear God.
Is just the.
Speaker 1: Worst.
And then here is another little quick video
of Ted Cruz leaving and again getting getting
the full treatment.
Good.
Go back to Cancun now.
More substantively, substantively, in terms
of New York City.
Ted Cruz voted against hurricane aid after
Hurricane Sandy ravaged New York and New Jersey
back in 2012 and then in 2017 after Hurricane
Harvey crushed Houston.
He was saying, give us money, give us money,
give us money.
And when you ask him, aren't you a hypocrite?
He was like, oh, no, no, no.
Sandy was all pork.
None of the money went to the victims, which
of course, was not true.
He's horrible, truly horrible.